so alright so Joey you got a half-hour
also can I just say this I here's
another thing is is that you and I are
similar in this way also is that we get
like three or four lines in a movie you
know like I remember like I watched that
movie taxi not taxi driver but the Jimmy
Fallon Queen Latifah TV right you're in
that movie right yeah and I remember
going watching the movie going the only
thing I remember is Joey Diaz being in
it he's so funny or spider-man yeah you
remember spider-man yeah the first one
yeah the second one I mean you were in
that 14 days one line oh yeah I reckon
pomegranate juice smoking dope in my
green room oh yeah two weeks one line
Joey you're too big to be hanging out in
the trash oh yeah go to the green room
when I booked that it was one day yeah
and then they call me in June I go call
it wardrobe when I went to wardrobe
night you start working next week I'm
like what are you talking about July
31st I'm like now those are the good old
days they don't know they'll let you sit
for two days or you're like in your
trailer and you fall asleep for like
seven or eight hours and you open your
eyes you don't know where you are and
did you get a knock and then some nerd
you're like wow lobster tails spider-man
- laughs laughs ride a and why people
still be in salads and apple pie
I mean lobster tails to go I got 19
lobster tails shoving lobster tails
every pocket have you ever done a movie
where they didn't even you were in even
in it at all
we're like they cut it out I think I
just did that I did that movie about
Howard Hughes my pretty gangster but I
was in my trailer when they called and
the two gangsters sat in the boot
so I sat across from Alec Baldwin yeah
and I think they cut it out because
nobody said they saw I got a check it's
so funny how I get residual checks for
movies I'm not even in yeah Wow like I
get checks for some reason but then I
get my checks too and I catch them more
the same I did that movie Paul I know
I'm in the director's cut or whatever
but in the original cut I remember like
you know leaving the
driving away from that scene going wow
that was really good I made everyone
laugh you know I mean and you get really
pumped up yeah and you tell people about
it I mean that new silent movie right
and it comes out and they go you weren't
in it and you're like oh [ __ ] my bad
when you text me your address the other
day yeah I'm not gonna repeat it yeah I
echo I know the street I just don't know
where this and I looked it up I go this
is my old code mystery you used to stay
open till 2:00 to 11 p.m. to 2 to 3
hours
11 a.m. oh wow that's long I'll get
drunk from 4:00 to 7:00 so you couldn't
call him he never does sell coke from 47
pound but his tip top hour and then he
then he shortened my curfew till 1:00 if
you don't have no cash it's one well if
you got cash it's two if you're fronting
you got throw one I would leave La Hoya
Comedy Store at a quarter to twelve yeah
and I would get right here I could do La
Hoya in an hour and fifteen an hour 20 I
do design these or 80 all the way to the
border yeah
but they ask you to stop for fruit and
from that everyone I do a hundred a
hundred a hundred no registration no
insurance
barely brake pads that's pretty [ __ ]
orient I remember one time I was in my
hotel our hotel room in San Diego like
by Tijuana and it was like 2:00 p.m. I
was sleeping in this hotel room and I
get a call and they go why are you what
are you at the table read
and I was so drugged out right cuz I had
just gotten pills from Tijuana I'm gonna
have a table read how [ __ ]
embarrassing is that I'm so drugged out
I can't even make it to a [ __ ]
Network table read
for shower so I did a movie I booked a
movie called pizza and bullets
the girl from the Godfather but I went
and shot the first scene and I'm like
I'm not going back
you were you did it and the next day I
had a 6:00 a.m. call and I got coked up
to the gills and they came knocking on
my door Jana and I grabbed the kid threw
him and [ __ ] they call the cops he's
hysterical oh why don't you want to be
in this movie I'm like I never want to
be in your [ __ ] movie again the
casting director called me said he never
booked me all everybody [ __ ] simple
and tell them that I was a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] yeah the director called me and
I yelled at him and now the directors
trying to be my friend on Lincoln then
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him I don't even have
Lincoln them but I saw his name I'm like
well this [ __ ] creepy dude
[Music]